منذ تنصيبه لنفسه ملكا مطلقا على عرشه
تويتر قبل نحو عشره ايام لا يمر يوم دون
ان يباغت الملياردير الى الماس مستخدمين
منصه وموظفيها بقرارات وخطوات جديده فبعد
اقالته لمسؤولين كبار وتسريح نحو نصف
موظفي تويتر واغلاق العديد من المكاتب
الخارجيه اضافه الى اطلاقه خدمه برسوم
قدرها ثمانيه دولارات شهريا لمن يريد
توفيق حسابه بالعلامه الزرقاء يبدا مشغل
الخط الساخن لشكاوى تويتر كما بات ماسك
يعرف نفسه بالكشف عن معالم افكاره بشان
كيفيه اداره جوهر عمل من الصعب بوصفها
شبكه للمحادثات العامه من خلال اصدار
قواعد التدوين على تويتر قواعد تبدو
وكانها تجيب على المخاوف التي رددها
كثيرون من امكانيه تحول منصه في عهده الى
ساحه المنفلته ينشر فيها كل شيء بلا قيود
او حدود او ضوابط لا سيما في ظل تسريحه
للفرق المسؤوله عن التحقق من المحتوى
وضماني حقوق الانسان يؤكد ماسك ان القواعد
تهدف الى ضمان مشاركه الجميع بافكارهم
ونقاشاتهم بحريه وامان ولذلك فان تويتر
سيمنع التالي تمجيد العنف او التهديد به
ضد فرد او مجموعه من الناس التهديد او
الترويج للارهاب او التطرف العنيف
الاستغلال الجنسي للاطفال
الانخراط في اساءات او مضايقات لشخص ما او
تحريض الاخرين على القيام بذلك السلوك
الذي يحض على الكراهيه فلا يجوز ترويج
العنف ضد الاخرين او تهديدهم او مضايقتهم
على اساس عراقيه واجتماعيا اودينيا كما
تعهد ماسك بان يزيل تويتر اي حسابات يحتفظ
بها مرتكبون هجمات الارهابيه او الهجمات
العنيفه لكن الاهم ربما في القواعد التي
نشرها ماسك تاكيد السعي لضمان الا يتم
استخدام المنصه في التلاعب او التدخل
بالانتخابات ويتضمن ذلك ان نشره او مشاركه
محتوى قد يؤدي الى تضليل الاشخاص بشان متى
واين وكيف يشاركون في عمليه انتخابيه كما
لا يجوز بحسب القواعد انتحال شخصيه
الافراد او الجماعات او المنظمات لتظليل
او اربيكي او خداع الاخرين اذ سبق لماسك
ان حضر قبل ايام حساب الممثله الامريكيه
كاثقرفا على تويتر بعد استخدام اسمه
وصورته على حسابها باعتبار ذلك انتحالا
لشخصيته لتكون بذلك اولى ضحاياه لكن تاكيد
الملياردير المثير للجدل بان القواعد هذه
ستتطور مع مرور الوقت قد يفتح الباب
مستقبلا امام تغييرات جديده من طرفها
تتجاوز تلك القواعد او تلتف حولها خصوصا
مع غياب اي جهه يمكن لها منعه
او كبح جماح افكاره مهما بدات صادمه او
سابحه بعكس التيار